he is an actor, producer, rapper, and song writer
news we called him the most powerful actor in Hollywood, and Forbes call him the most bankable star worldwide.
he is worth over two hundred and fifty million dollars.
he is will smith.
and he is a top10 world of success.
don't ever let somebody tell you, ''you can't do some,''
not even me,
all right?
all right..
you got a dream, you gotta protect it.
people can't do some themselves, they wanna tell you ''you can't do it.''
you want some, go, get it. Period.
we didn't grow up with the son's dad, where we were was where we were gonna be
in a we grow up with the son's dad where we were almost didn't matter because we will be coming something greater.
there are the concept that .....
i don't wanna be.... ah....an icon.
i wanna be an idea.
you know, i wanna represent an idea. i wanna represent possibilities.
i wanna represent.. magic, right? that you and universe in two plus two equals four
two plus two only equals four if you accepted two plus two equals four
two plus two is gonna i want to be. you know...
there is a... there is a
there is a redemptive power that making a choice has, you know, rather than feeling like your affect to all the things that are happening.
make a choice like you just decide what is gonna be, who you are gonna be, how you are gonna do it. just decide.
and then from that point,
the universe is going to get out your way
it's like it's water. it's want to move go around stuff. you know.
so for me,  i wanna represent possibilities.
i wanna represent the idea that you really can make what you want what my favorite books is that the alchemist Paulo Coelho.